サッブパパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダ サチッッタパリオダパナン エタング ブッダナ サーサナン
月例講演会をこれからあのネット中継で皆様に伝えたいと思っております
普段皆様の顔を見ながら
反応を見ながら 話の内容をね
変えたりはしていましたけど
今回はまあどうなることかと
自分でもよくわからないんです
では早速始まりましょうか
えっと じゃあスライドの大丈夫
あの 今日のテーマは調べる力ですね
で 仏教ではこのデータを検索する方法を
あるまあある程度ではなくて
全体的にありまして あの
あまりこの特別テーマとして扱っていないんですね
どんな経典を見ても 大体データ検索する方法
情報検索する方法っていうのは入ってはあるんですね
至って簡単に言えば この何でも入っていいわけじゃなくて
我々は選ばなくちゃいけない
ある情報を捨ててある情報を入れるということはしなくちゃいけない
だから この選択するフィルターが一人一人持たなくちゃいけないんですね
だから どんなフィルターを持っているのかっていうことについても考えなくちゃいけないんですね
面白いことは この仏教徒に特別にフィルターを教えているわけではなくて
どんな生命も一切のデータを
世にあるすべてのデータを受けていっているわけじゃないんです
みんなそれぞれ自分なりのフィルターを持っていて
好きなことを心に入れて
まあそうでないものは排除したりするんですね
だから排除する場合はやり方が 2つありますね
そういうデータあることすら知らない場合もあります
あるいはデータが心に触れるんだけど
もう関係ないということで無視する
この 2つの方法で我々は排除するんですね
だから 世の中で人間同士のデータにしたっても
もう大量のデータがあるんだけど
我々はそんなことはあるということですらわからない
ですから それはもうフィルタリングされてますね
とっくに それから 耳に入る
目に入るデータの中でも
こんなのは面白くない
こんなのは関係ないという感じでフィルタリングしているんですね
そこで まず理解するべきことは
我々はどんなフィルターを持っているのかと
それであの人間別々に喋る時
キリがないんだから 仏教は生命をまとめて喋ってるんですね
人間別々に言えば 例えばプロの音楽家がいる
で プロの音楽家があるフィルターを持っていて
世の中のデータをあの区別したりはする
画家がいるな それは画家のデータの受け取り方はまた違う
子育ての母親だったら
まあ外へ出て散歩をすると
自分の心に入るデータがまた変わるんですね
ですから 一人一人のフィルターがそれぞれ一人の環境によって変わるんですね
環境というか 心のセッティングによって変わるんですね
だからそれについて喋ったってもうキリがなくなっちゃうんですね
だから生命のフィルターは何ですか？と
ベーシックフィルター
このベーシックフィルターっていうのは
この基礎的なフィルターですね
生きていきたいでしょ？みんな
ああ 死にたくてしょうがないと思っている生命はいません
誰だって生きていきたい
その生きていられるかないかっていうところでフィルタリングしているんですね
だから存在欲ですね 存在欲が各生命によって変わった情報になるんですね
例えばカラスさんの 存在欲があって
カラスさんが生き続けるためにどんなデータを取ればいいか
どんなデータが危険で排除で排除されればいいかと
別ですね そこでカラスさんが危険だと排除するデータが
我々人間としては別に危険じゃないよという感じになるかもしれません
そこで猫さんがいて 猫さんが存在する存在欲あるんだから
例えば食べる場合はね
まあこんな例えば切ったトマトもあって
もう何だったっけ？玉ねぎもあって
そこら辺カリカリもあると
3つの皿に それでもうひどい匂いで嫌がるんですね
玉ねぎなんかはね トマトなんかはそんなに匂いないんだけども
もう嫌がるんですね 肉のように見えるんだけどね
赤くてもう見ようともしない
それは危険データ それでカリカリの方に飛んで
それは食べる そちらに人間が来たら
人間はカリカリの方には見ようともしない
この玉ねぎとトマトの皿の方が食べるものとして認識します
そういうことで 各生命の存在を維持するために必要な条件によってフィルタリングは変わっていくんです
でも基本的に よくわかりやすいね
存在欲を支えるためのデータフィルタリングなんですね
それで 例えば人間の種類はね
人間という種はね そんなに生きることはそんなに大変大きい問題だとは思ってないんですね
楽に生き生きられると思ってはいるんです
それは妄想ではなくて
現実的に人間思うよりも人間は楽に生きられ
生きる 生きられます 生きています
頭が悪いんだから大変だ
大変だと泣き叫んでるだけで
そこで楽に生きられるならば
存在に対してこの付属品
あってもなくてもいいものね
ピアスみたいな感じでね
ネックレスみたいな感じで
ネックレスネックレスなかったら女性は死にましたとかね
というのはありませんね
口紅がなくなって あの女性が死にましたとはないですね
だからもう口紅つけるのは他問題ないからなんですね
食べて幸せに生きられるんですね
だからプラスアルファで余計なことを加えるんですね
人間の世界を見ると このこういうアクセサリーばっかしで
そこでデータが大量になっているんですね
このアクセサリー探していることは
男性も女性もみんなやってますよ
で 例えば趣味っていうものはね
趣味がないと人は死ぬわけないでしょうに
生きていられるんだから
余った時間でなんとか楽しく過ごそうではないかということで
趣味などなど作ったりはするんですね
そうなってみると 人間というのはこの
ただ時間無駄遣いをするために大量にデータ取り入れているんですね
知らなくた知らない 知らないならば死にますよっていう危機感ではなく
もう大量に余計なデータ知って
本を読むは 音楽を聴くはね
踊るは歌うは楽器を奏でるはね
旅行に行くはとかね いろんなことをたくさんやってはいるので
その上で政治論を語るはね
経済論語るは 精神はなんぞやと
なんか余計なことを考えるは
宗教を勉強するはとか
そんなのは必要でしょうかということもあります
疑問にはなりますけどね
とにかく大量にデータを
受け取ったりしているんですね
はい それで人間同士でお互い馬鹿にし合うんですね
例えば女性の家族を持っている女性の場合は
まあスーパーで野菜はどんな日で安く売っているのかとかね
キャベツはどんな時安く売るのかとかね
卵の安売りはいつですか？とか
それを考えているんですね
だからチラシなんかあったら
すごく真剣にそれ読んだりする
男はそれに女にそれしか興味ないやとバカにするんですね
あれってすごい人のデータに対してバカにすることなんですね
しかし この女性の方々にとっては大事なデータなんです
生きるために必要なデータなんです
だからリモコンを作って
それであのドローンでも飛ばしている男性には
キャベツはどうでもいいや
もう でもその人も食べてはいるんだけどね
だからそこでこの他人が受け取っているデータを馬鹿にするという
すごい悪い性格も表れているんですね
ではなくて 我々は ある個人が受けているデータで
その個人がダメになるかならないかと考えて
そこら辺は教えてあげてもいいんですよ
ただ 自分の感情で人の知識をあまり馬鹿にしてはいけないと思います
はい まあ一応基本的なそういうことで
だから私はタイトル 1 で何を調べる？というテーマにしたんですね
こう考えましょう 知る知りべきもの
知り得るものっていうのは
大量にあります 無数にあります
例えば推測でコウモリさんに聞こえる音は人間に聞こえない
それ知りたいと そんなのはカットしましょう
で 昆虫たちに見える世界は我々に見えない
蝶々には人間より幅広く色を見える
じゃあそれも蝶々のように見たいと
いらん そんなのはいらんだからないんです
能力は ではなくて 一人の人間にでも知り得るデータが認識できるデータっていうのは無数に無料にあります
無限にあります ですから
我々はちゃんと検索する
しなくちゃいけないんですね
はい これはどうしても欠かせないことなんですね
で まずは個人個人がその個人に必要なデータを調べる
ですから その個人が私に私が何を知った方がよろしいかと自分で判断して行っています
それから頼まれて 他人の他人に必要な情報を調べるんですね
仕事をするとき 我々がよくやっているのは
自分にはどうでもいいことなんですけど
会社が会社に頼まれて
会社のためにいろんなことを調べたりする
時々 大学の研究している研究者たちでも
教授にこれこれ調べなさいと言ったら
調べてデータはデータを教授にあげたりはする
でもそのデータ 自分の研究には関係ないかもしれませんね
そうやって他人に頼まれてもデータを調べることはします
はい いきなりテーマ変わっちゃうんですね
調べるのはいいんだけど
何でも取るんじゃなくて
この信頼性あるのかと
それは大事なんですね
ですから 教授が何かこれこれどうなってるのかと聞いたら
そこら辺の誰かのおばさんにおじさんにそれ聞いて
さっさと教授に報告していいわけじゃないんですね
ですから 信頼性っていうのはリライアビリティーなんですね
はい ですから 我々はまず信頼性って何ですかと
今日教えられるのはそれなんですよ
信頼性 それってどういうことかと調べてみましょう
はい ですから 信頼性についてこれから説明します
当たり前 事実であること
真理であることは嘘だったら意味がないんですね
だから事実であること
本当に確かにその通りであると
ということが必要なんです
それで信頼できる それから
このデータの場合は可能性
実証しているデータがありますね
あるいは実証は可能か
あるいは推測か これは推測のデータとかね
意見か伝承されているか
信仰迷信か 希望好みか
はい 次のラインで  そういうものも調べなくちゃいけないんですね
ちょっと英語にもしてみましたけど
まあなんとなくこのそういうテーマが英語っぽいなんです
あまり日本語にちょっと合わないような気がするんですね
まあ例えば今の COVID19 の問題があって
この前に最初に 若者 若者
子供に病気かからないと言っていたんですね
それって事実でしょうかと
証拠はありますかとかって言うと
ある程度で子供も感染とか何とか一緒にいたんだけど
何のこともなかったと
あるいは子供たち自分も感染しているのに
何のあれも服 何て言いますか
病気にもならなくて もう治っているとかね
安心だと思ったところで
子供が同じ COVID19 にかかって亡くなったケースはまだあるんですね
だからそういうのは確実に実証されて終わっているデータではなくて
可能性か プロバビリティーを言っているんですね
例えば年寄りは死ぬ確率はすごく高いと言ってということは
コロナにかインフルエンザにかかった年寄りは 100パー死ぬかというと
そうじゃないんですね
だから そういう風にも我々はデータを受け取りますね
今もう誰でもコロナウイルスはやっぱり年寄りには
やばいと一般的に言う
これは確固たる事実でもないんですね
まあまあ いろいろケース見たらそんな通りやという風に
だからそういうことで
それで意見もありますね
だから じゃあ自分の国から今ちょっと例出しますね
自分の国でアーユルヴェーダという医療制度が古くからあるんですね
しかし コロナウイルスというのはウイルスだから
これは現代病だから まあもう現代医学でもそれを治す方法は持ってない
だから死者に治るまで待たなくちゃいけない
それでアーユルヴェーダの方々は
まあそんなことではなくて
我々はもう免疫力を高める薬くらい持ってますよとかね
で あれやこれやと言ったりしているんですね
それって実証済みではなくて
意見だと私は思いますね
なぜならば 昔は西洋薬飲まないで
人々は元気で健康でいた
だから昔はコロナ 19ウイルス COVID 19 にかからなかったって話にならないでしょうね
だから単純に昔そういう伝染病なかった
あってももうすぐすぐ 2日
3日で治りましたということから
意見推測して意見を語る
それで何を隠そう 私もまあ 2日
3日読みましたけど アーユルヴェーダ薬があって
あの これ混ぜて煎じて飲むんだけど
一つであの体の抵抗力を上げる
もう一つの薬で この このウイルスなどなどに攻撃できる力を上げると
2種類入ってる薬があって
まあ一応まあ 2日  3日読んだんだから
ちょっと喉の喉が弱くなっていてね
まあそれは微妙に治ったような気がします
だからそういうのは実証済みということにならないんですね
だから まあ日本にしたっても
いろいろそういうもう考えているあるんで
意見ですよ これは意見ですとはっきりした方がよろしいんですね
時々伝承されている 特にあの文化がある国々に
まあ日本でもアジアの国々でも結構長い文化を持っているんだから
いろんなくだらんこと伝承されているんですね
これは本当かどうかさっぱりわからんんだけど
我々はこの文化の中で育ち育てられたんだから
何のことなく まあそのことやとすぐ信じてしまうんですね
例えば中国人は獅子舞で悪霊がなくなるとね
まあ今の中国人はそう思ってはないかもしれませんだけど
それでもやります 面白いんだからね
日本でも赤鬼 青鬼が来て
なんとかなんとかゴチャゴチャやったら
まあ病気がなくなって
商売繁盛じゃなくて あのえっと
農業の方は何といいますか
五穀豊穣 五穀豊穣になるんだと
昔は真面目に信じていたでしょうね
今は信じてないんだけど
やっぱり伝承だから真剣にやってますね
この通りでやる この通りでやるべきとかね
例えば今も青鬼 赤鬼の踊りがあるんだけど
まあ現代流行ってるポピュラー音楽に踊りましょうとはやりませんね
まあロックミュージックでもね
奏でて じゃあ鬼踊りやらでやらない
それから信仰当選ね 信仰があって
あの信仰だから正しいとね
いう場合もあるし 迷信もあるし
まあいろいろ それから知らんうちに希望
好みが事実やという場合もありますよ
だからそこら辺で我々はこのデータを送ってる前にデータを受け取る
この基本的な能力に欠けているんですよ
要するに包丁でキャベツを千切りにしようではやる前に包丁の握り方すら知らない
だったらもう怪我するんだからやめろというしかないんで
やめちゃうと包丁 キャベツのみじん切りもできなくなる
だからこのデータの調べ方
信頼性 信頼性 どう成り立つ成り立つのかっていう
ここら辺はあの仏教でははっきり教えてますよ
あの有名なカーラム経典でね
聖典であるからといって
鵜呑みにするなよと 自分で調べなさい
伝承だからといって どうでもいい
自分で調べなさい すごい論理にぴったし合いますよと
まあ関係ないやと 論理にあっても事実ではない場合もありますね
それで 10種類の項目を教えているんですね
最近のお釈迦様が自分自身がブッダだからといってね
鵜呑みにするなよと だから最初からも個人にこの調べる力をあげているんです
ないならばもう見過ぎなさいよ
でなきゃ話にならんよと
最初からもう人間としても成り立たないんですよ
だから今の世界 なんでハチャメチャになってるのかというと
みんなもう頭ぶん殴られた豚みたいに走り回っているだけで
どこに走っているのか
何のために走るのかもさっぱりわからないんですね
人に聞いたら あなたは何をやっているの？私もわかりませんと
でも何かやっているんだよという状態になってますね
だからみんな暇ですかと聞いたら
何言うのか 忙しくてしょうがないんだと
では何をやっているのかと言ったら
何もやってないんです
そういう何かもう もうたとえもないんですよ
もう人間の生き様には
だからそのポイントは
この この能力ないんですね
免疫ついてないんですね
あの このリライアビリティー信頼性
チェックする能力ないんです
これで自慢に言いますけど
だから皆さんに真似できないんだから自慢にしたんですね
で 大体人が喋ると 本当のことを喋っているか
嘘のことを喋って知って喋っているのか
推測喋っているのかと
まあ言葉で波長ですぐわかるんです
ただ自分の意見を相手に無理やり押し込めているのかと
あるいは興奮しちゃって
ガチャガチャガチャガチャガチャガチャ病気な病気なように喋っているのかとかね
まあすぐあの経典をよく学んで
それなりに試してみると
至って簡単にわかります
例えば何かあのね すごくいいものを見つかったよと言ったら
いいものを見つかったよというあの波長で
あのいらん持って帰ってください
見ようともしないで返すことはできます
あれ 波長に入ってるんですよ
この信頼性の だからそれぐらい能力あればありがたいんだけど
これはどう育てるのか
私にはよくわからんだから次にいきます
はい その中で我々には使う情報というのは実装済み
あるいは実装可能ってもの 2つだけなんです
だからご飯を 白いご飯食べるとか
ふりかけをかけて食べても悪くないやと
あれは実証済みなんですね
まあふりかけかけたらそれなりに
まあ食べやすくというか
さらに美味しくはなる
だから実証済みですけど
子供しかふりかけ探せないんですね
どういうことかよくわからないんです
私はふりかけは使いません
年寄りだから だからあの実証済みというデータだったら
あの使えますね その場合は
誰かが先に勇気を持って実証しなきゃダメなんですね
はい 食べるものの場合は
我々は本当にびっくりするものも今食べていますね
わさびとかね でも最初にそれ試した人の気持ちを考えたら
どうですかね でも長い間わさび
いろんなことに食べてきて
今は別にわさび見たらこれ怖いとか誰も思わない
わさびなめたらもう大変
なんか頭ぶん殴ったような気がしますけど
それでももう食べるんです
なぜならば いくつかの料理にわさびは合うという風にもう実証済みなんですね
実証済みだから そのデータ使える
2番目は実証可能でなければね
だからこういう風に こういう風にやってみたら
このあんた言ってることは本当かないか調べられますよと
一つはもうOKなデータ
もう一つは あの まあ調べることは可能で
その2種類のデータしか人間には役に立たない
しかし 面白いことに その 2つも捨てて
どうでもいいデータで頭がゴミだらけになっているんです
調べる方法もないし 実証されてもないし
まあ信じているわ信じているわ
頭いっぱいそういうゴミのデータばっかしで
あれはゴミのデータありすぎちゃって
必要なデータには入る場所がない
ハードディスクがフルです
はい まあそれでポイントわかると思います
はい 次に考えてみましょうか
これはあえて私は使うポイントなんです
このリライアビリティの延長なんです
リライアビリティって
あの信頼性のちょっと延長したもので
バイアス はい 次 このバイアスというのはカタカナでバイアスというんですね
この自分の感情 好みなどで情報をカラーリングする
ペイントする 色付ける
だから白い紙をね 持ってきてくださいと言ったら
その人はいろんなもうそこでいろんなカラーペンでいろんなごちゃごちゃごちゃ落書きしてからくれたら
私に白い紙の役目はできなくなるんですね
ちょっと封筒持ってきてと言ったら
持ってくる人は子供ですとも
子供はあのパステルのね
色鉛筆の箱を持っていて
持ってくる間でいろんなこと
好きな色を描いたり ウサギの絵を描いたり
花の絵を描いたりして
はい どうぞとくれる 使えなくなっちゃうんですね
それがバイアスなんです
だから その程度だったらバイアスが悪いとすぐわかるでしょう
そんなに可愛い話じゃないんです
バイアスは 我々のどんな人間も
自分の心に入るデータを自分の感情と
それから 好み 好みというのは嫌なものも入りますよ
好まない 好まないもの
それによって もう変えますよ
私も もうこれは可愛い例なんですけど
だからある人が私に何か言うんですね
この まあ名前を付けましょう
Aさんと B さん  A さんが私に何か言う
あの B さんがこう言いましたと
そこでこの A さんが B さんのことをすごく嫌いですね
B さんをバカにしたいんですね
そこで B さん聞いて こんなこと言っちゃったんだけどと言ったら
変な顔をするんですね
そうすると 私はこの A さんの顔表情を見て判断しちゃうと
A さん捨てるデータのバイアスにやられたことになるんです
どうせ A さんが B さんのこと嫌いだから
どうったことろくなろくな情報ことではない
もう誰だってそんなこと言えるんだよという態度で私に言うんですからね
そうすると私も B さんが言ったこと
まあ別にどうったことないという気持ちにならなくちゃいけない
これ  A さんの狙いはそれなんです
データ純粋に清らかに伝えることではなくて
自分のバイアスを理解してくださいということで
だから封筒を持ってくる子供が褒めて欲しがってるんですね
ああ 君 きれい うさぎちゃんも描いちゃったんですね
君はと でも これを仕事のお手紙出したければ
これ使えないんですけどね
はい 次のポイントに行きます
いろいろなマンモスニュース組織があるでしょ
BBC  ABC ロイター
アルジャジーラとか すべてバイアスに凍り固まっているんです
これは BBC ニュースですと言ったらみんな乗るでしょ
ロイターのレポーターですと
すぐ乗るんです 乗らずにいられないんです
例えばイランに何か起きたと
このロイターの何々さんが報告しましたと言っちゃうんだけど
場所に行っているんです
現場から言うんですね
でもバイアスです  BBC は昔
私も若い頃ね  BBC だけ世界で一番信頼性があるニュースチャンネルだと思っていたんです
イギリス人のね ものすごい誇り高い
もうもうものすごい よくよく見ると全くくだらないんです
自分たちのこの白人至上主義のあれで
全部無理やりデータを補完する
アメリカのニュースではもう話にならない
もう それで中国のニュースチャンネルは何といいますか
あの  新華社  なんかだから中国は自分のバイアスで放送する
なんで世界に一つのニュースメディアあればいいでしょうに
バイアスがあることみんな認めてるんです
アルジャジーラ始めた時はもう私もよくミニエボやるんですよ
西洋の BBC と ABC と
それから CNN などなどがね
ロイターものすごくバッシング
イスラム文化を一つも情報正しく伝えません
では我々はもう金もあるんだから
マンモスメディアを作りましょうと
アルジャジーラ作ったんです
そこでもテロリストの情報でも何でも流すんだから
あの ある程度でバイアスなくなくではないんです
後で調べたらあんまりにもバイアスなんです
だからこのバイアスだから困ると思って
もう 100種類のメディアが現れたって
もう 100種類のバイアスあるだけでしょうに
はい どうすればいいんですかね
だから日本の方々は NHK というメディア信頼するでしょ？バイアスがすごい派手にあるんです
ものすごい派手なんです
NHK の決まりで バイアスで
この色眼鏡で通すデータしか発表しません
ですから これって問題大きいんですよ
友達に聞いても その友達にバイアスがあるんです
私は仏教学をちらちらと舐めていた時期があったんだから
そこですごい立派な先生だと尊敬していた
で この先生の本なん 本だったら
あの 参考になる 勉強になるところを読んでみたっても
やっぱり先生のバイアスが入っているんです
それ言ってしまっちゃって
昔 私はかなり誹謗中傷を受けたこともあります
あんな偉大なる方にあなた何言うのかと
何様のつもりですかと
だからバイアスはみんなにあるんですから
仏教ではすごいんですよ
このバイアスの顔を外して
皮を外してデータ見る能力を上げているんです
だから我々自分もバイアスを持っている
他人もバイアスを持っていると
お母さんはお母さんのバイアスと子供は子供のバイアスを持っていると
だから子供は何か報告すると
そのまま事実ではないんです
その報告から 子供が入れたバイアスの皮を剥がして取らなくちゃいけない
逆はいいんだよ 母親が言うことを何でも子供は聞いてないんだからね
子供は母親のバイアスを剥がして
自分のバイアスを入れて理解するんです
で 夫婦の間でも時々夫婦喧嘩になるんですよ
女性が自分のバイアスで何かデータを情報を男に言うんだけど
男は男のバイアスでこれを却下するんですね
違うだろうと そうじゃないだろうと相手に言うんです
と女性がカンカン怒っちゃうんです
男性は男性のバイアスで大事なデータを言うと
女性の方がもううるさい
あんた黙っていなさいと言うんです
それで男性喧嘩になる
これ バイアスの問題なんですね
はい このバイアスはのカラクリありましてね
我々は何か知る場合は
そのままあるものを知ることしないんです
自分が脳の脳みその中であるストーリーを作るんです
覚えるのはストーリーであって
データではないんです
これ 毎日 24時間起こるんです
何を見ても 何を聞いても
どんな情報入っても すぐ頭の中で瞬時にストーリーを作るんです
それからストーリーは自分が作ったものだから
それを覚えているんです
それを相手に伝えるんです
これ 具体的な例を言い始められちゃうと
これだけで別な講義になりますから
次のセクションセクションに行きます
その上 個人にはまあこのバイアスがありますとね
まあとにかくまあわかりやすく言えば
例えば BBC が BBC のストーリーを語る
今はもうみんな面倒くさいんだから
ニュースストーリーと言うんです
英語ではストーリー単語はもうへっちゃらで使っています
正しくはレポートでしょ
レポートではないんで
今はレポートではなくてストーリーなんです
そこで BBC のストーリーを私は自分の
バイアスに入れて判断するんです
例えば中国のことを言えない人だったら
BBC は中国ではすごいことをこういう発明したあれやこれと報告したとしましょう
それで BBC のストーリーなんです
本当に中国の人の出来事じゃないんです
そこで BBC の人を見たら
こちらが BBC のストーリーをそのまま鵜呑みにしないで
自分のバイアスでさらに
もうやっぱり思った通りで
あの連中はとんでもないやつらやっていう風に思ったりはするんですね
だから わかりやすい例で言えば
我々みんな私もやられているのは北朝鮮なんですね
北朝鮮の人はね のことを情報流してるでしょ
全部 この人を馬鹿にする
例えば世界地球 今あのウイルスの問題で世界大騒ぎしているんだけど
あの人はミサイルを発射すると
で そこで北朝鮮でも何距離でしたっけ？わからんだけど
ミサイルなんか発射しましたと報告すればいいんだけど
ちょっと今の時期でという一言を入れるんです
あの一言葉で相当なストーリーなんですね
だからバイアス入れるっていうのはすっごい簡単にできます
そこで我々はなに？いや
なんだ このバカが 今ミサイル実験する時じゃないだろうやって
ガチャガチャガチャガチャ言うんだけど
あのバカが何を思ってるか
私も誰もわからないんです
結局は それで私も使ったバカという単語も
バイアスでやられた言葉なんです
はい それで人間のよく間違いあります
情報が多い方が多いと
はい 情報は事実真理であるならば
2 たす 2 イコール 4 のように一つしかないんです
情報は正しければそれで終わりです
これは何かイエス様も何か気になっていたみたいで
どこかに聖書に新約聖書にあなた方の言葉はイエスノーのところだけにして下さいと
だから事実を語るならば
事実でイエスかノーかと
で まあだから本当に正しい事実だったら
本当の状態データだったら
一つですよ はい 多数の意見見解あるとは
語る人のバイアスで見方で
この主観で事実を解説していることです
何かについてたくさんの意見がある
で  COVID 19 を抑えるためにどうすればいいかというと
いろんな意見が出てくると
誰もはっきりした方法わからない
それは科学世界だから
みんなそれはちゃんと
よくわからないんだけど
正直に言ってますね あの...もしかすると空気感染はしないかも
人と人から感染する ですから
もう 2メートルぐらい距離を置いた方がいいとかね
2メートル距離で付き合ってみても
感染する可能性はあるし無いし
わからないんですね で
マスク着けるべきかないかっていうね
議論があったでしょ だから今ほとんどみんなマスク着けてますけど
これははっきりした実証済みじゃないんです
まあとりあえず着けた方がいいんじゃない？ということになっただけで
で マスク着けたからといって感染する場合感染しますよ
こんなもうマスクから通りますからね
だから鼻口などから通るんだからね
だから一番わかりやすい
誰か言ったんだけど 顔を触るなよと
いかなる場合でも その方が私は結構信頼性に近いやと
問題は顔を触らないでいられるのかと
体のどんな部分よりも先に触るのは顔
顔なんですね まあとにかく
そうやって今我々悩んでいる COVID-19 のウイルスについても意見あるわあるわあるわあるわ
もう一つ意見というのは
一旦感染して治った人に再び病気にかかるかないかと
だから 2回目も感染するかと
答えはわからない で 免疫はあるんです
免疫はどれぐらい持ちますかと
答えはわからないんです
1週間か  1ヶ月か  1年か一生かわからないんです
で 私の個人的な主観もあります
これはもうコロナと大騒ぎしたっても
これはただのインフルエンザでしょ
インフルエンザは一生一回しかかかるという保証はないでしょ
かかるはかかる 一つ治ったらまた別なインフルエンザにかかるって
だからこのウイルスはどうっても変化するやつだから
まあ一生怖くて生活する羽目になります
で 風邪と同じなんですよ
風邪を引いたらまた風邪を引きませんとはありえないんです
風邪ウイルスも同じ仲間ですからね
症状軽いんだから風邪というんですね
症状がひどい ひどい場合はインフルエンザというんですね
肺炎になったらかなりきついんですね
だから溺れて死ぬ羽目になるんですね
そういうことで この意見たくさんあってありがたいんですかね
私が仏教的に言うのは
意見たくさんあると 誰もまだわかってないねという気持ちなんです
そうすると心が軽くなるんです
何かに盲信的に乗る必要はないんだと
まあまあまあ 五分五分
中途半端等の程度の理解で
そうも言ってる あれも言ってるという
ジャイナ教の教祖様のような態度の方が楽ちんなんですね
まあそうも言われている
という風にするしかないんです
それで情報が多ければ多いほど事実は隠れるんです
この政治世界で国際問題でよくあるんですね
いろんな出来事についてレポート書くは書くは書くは
レポートについてさらにレポート書くは
評価のレポートが出てくると
もう膨大なデータが出てくるんですね
本当の状況はわからないんですね
例えば昔もう最近ですけどね
アルカイダという組織があって
テロ行為をしましたと
それだけで誰一人いまだにわかってないんですね
あのアルカイダのあれ
誰でしたっけ？ビンラディンがなんでビンラデンがそのこうに行ってしまったのかと
誰もそれを研究しないんだ
ビンラデンが悪い もうイスラム教が悪いと
この人たちをテロリストだと
そればっかりで 自分の主観見解言いふらすという情報ありすぎ
ビンラディンがどこに隠れているかすらわからない
今アフガニスタンに隠れているんだと
あちらに隠れてこちら
それすらとわからない
時々ビンラディン昔はね
報告発表するんですよ
発表したら これ本当にビンラディンか別人かわからない
それでアメリカの CIA が精密に音声をチェックしたところで
あれは本当のビンラディンの声でしたとかね
それも信頼できません
それで情報ありすぎてデータが本当のこと隠れたんですね
私は今まで思った思っているのは
なぜビンラディンのような人々はテロ行為に行ってしまったのかと
なんで反社会性態度を取ったのかと
反人類態度 誰がどんな理由でそこに押し入れるというんですか？押し込まれたのかと
それ解決しないと 人は人を殺したら殺人はけしからんと言っても答えじゃないんです
なぜその人は殺人犯になったのかと
そちらにもありますね
それは見ようともしない
それで日本でも犯罪心理学教授なんだらかんだりいるんだけど
もう笑っちゃうんで 話聞いちゃうと
もうバイアスの上でバイアスで
あの私たち冷静に犯人立てないで
もののことを見て どちらでも悪口
お前はバカ あんたはバカというふうな態度を取らないんですね
だから 訴える側も訴えられる側ではどちらでも有罪だという態度は取らないんです
だから これ面白いんですよ
だから裁判官をイメージしましょう
A さんが B さんを訴える
それで私は審判する  A さんが有罪です
B さん  B さんは有罪です
みんな 10 万罰金 訴えた人も訴えられた人も
それでなんか変な審判になるでしょうね
でも世の中はそういうことなんです
B さんが私の財布を盗んだと
だから A さんが被害者だと
本当に被害者？純粋な被害者
それなりに 財布を盗まれるぐらい
そいつならこいつの財布盗んでもいいやっていう
いうふうな いろいろあるでしょうに
だから財布を盗まれるように
生活して B さんを盗人にさせたあなたは有罪で
10 万罰金と 人の金を盗んだあなたに 10 万罰金だと
はい 帰ってくださいと言った方がいいと思いますよ
だから それをこの面白いエピソードを作ったのは
まあこれはマジナイフ取りじゃないんです
作ったのは この情報がありすぎて
本当に知るべきものは隠れて隠れて隠れてしまうんです
だから情報が多いということは全然ありがたくないんです
はい 次に行きます だったら情報少ない方がいいんですね
はい 情報が少ないなら信頼性が弱いんですね
だって情報少ないでしょ？十分調べて研究されてないので
得られる知識に確実性が
いわゆる信頼性が弱い
情報が少ないんだったらね
もう信頼できんね 調べてないんです
はい 事実を明確にするまで必要な情報が存在しない
時々それもあります 例えば
縄文人の生活習慣どうですかと聞いちゃ
情報がないね あれは縄文人のまあ
あの もうゴミ捨て場だけでしょう
ゴミ捨て場を発掘して
こういう生活で こういう生活
あまりもうよくわからないんですよ
もう 考古学はいい例なんですよ
まあ日本だけではなくて
世界のね 本当にもうどうしようもない情報がいくつか残っていて
そこからストーリーを組み立てなくちゃいけないんです
だから科学者だから それなりにストーリーを組み立てますけど
その通りってことじゃないね
例えば恐竜に対して子供が興味を持ってるんだから
恐竜の模型作ってるでしょうに
見たい人は一人もないんだけどね
だから私は時々子供が面白がっちゃうと
この恐竜の皮膚の色はどうやって決めたの？骨しか見つかってないでしょうにと
だから子供のあの面白い世界にちょっと穴を開けておくんですね
で これ穴開けるんじゃなくて
私は教育してますから
何でも鵜呑みにするなよと
そこら辺で推測 感情 気持ちいっぱいあるんだよと
はい そういうことで 結論は情報が多すぎだったら
事実は隠れてわからなくなります
情報が少ないんだったら
事実は知り得ないんです
どうしますかね はい だからこれですよ
何でも知る必要ないんです
情報が無数無限なので
全てを知る必要はないんです
自分に役に立つ情報という枠に入れる情報を知るようにします
もう世の中のことはすべて知らなくていいんです
自分の役に立ちますかと
それだけで十分です ですから
膨大なデータ量からほんのちょっと取るだけです
あの例を言います 東京都でね
水道がありますね ものすごい人々がいるんだからね
ものすごい量の水を水道で供給しています
でも私はガラスいっぱいで水を飲んで
それ十分でしょ？いくらでも蛇口から水出るから全部飲む
何考えてるんですかね？いくらでも情報あるから全部知る
だったら蛇口から出て水が出るならば全部飲みなさい
結局は水道局の水全部飲み干さなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうでしょ
しかし 水道局はどんどんどんどん川の水を持ってきて
また浄化して流しちゃうんだから
ありえない話でしょうに
情報ってそういうものなんです
水道局から供給している水道水なんです
私たちはガラス一杯か半分で十分です
無駄な知識は人を破壊しますね
あの例でわかりますね
無駄に情報を入れると
その人は人生が破壊する
はい 次のポイントに行きます
次のポイントで役に立つ情報って何ですか？と
うん たくさんスライドありますから
早く行きます 進みます
生きるために欠かせない情報
それは役に立ちます はい
次 娯楽に関する情報 みんな人間娯楽も好きなんですね
だから娯楽の情報 はい
他を支配管理するための情報ね
これも結構得るんで 私は聞いた話なんですけど
犬を飼っている人々は犬の飼い主
学校に行くんですね 犬を支配するための情報を知るためなんです
はい 次 無駄に時間を過ごすための情報などなどがあり
人はスマートに選択するべきです
だからネットやらね これを無駄な時間使うためでしょ？携帯とかはね
だから無駄な時間で携帯でゲームやってもいいし
新幹線に乗って携帯でゲームやるか
また その時別なね 本を読むとかね
あるいは携帯で役に立つ料理番組でも見るとかね
それもできますよ だからスマートになってほしい
人間がデータあるから知る必要はないということはポイントなんですね
例えば 娯楽に関するデータ取る人いてるでしょ
もう病気になっちゃうんですね
探す 探して探し 追っかけに追っかけしたり
いろんなメモラビリアといういろんな記念品をね
買ったり買い回ったり
いろんなことをやったりして
なんだこりゃっていう風に思ったりするんだけど
すごい金もなくなっちゃうしね
借金してでも有名なタレントさんの写真入りサイン入りのなんとか推しとかね
はい ですから面倒くさい
ブッダが言う役に立つ情報は何なのかと調べましょう
簡単です 人格向上に必要なデータ
はい 自分と他人に幸福安らぎを与えるためのデータ
これは聖書の言葉のように覚えておけば
抜群に幸せになります
頭がものすごく健康になります
今 頭っていうのはゴミ屋敷でしょうね
もう破裂寸前なんです
爆発寸前なんです これにすればはい
心を清らかにするための情報
汚い心を清浄にする情報
感情を乗り越えるための方法
我々は感情に負けるんですね
いつでも いくら頭の良い人間でいたっても
感情が出てきたら なんでバカなことをするのかとわからないぐらいアホなバカなことをするんですね
だから感情に勝たなくちゃいけないですね
これ 感情っていつ爆発するかわからないんです
COVID-19 よりも恐ろしいんです
COVID-19 は物質だからね
まあ管理できるだけど
感情は管理できない どんな時爆発するかわからない
だからこれとても危険
だから感情を乗り越えるデータを勉強しましょう
はい 次に行きます それから現象
幻覚の殻を破って ありのままの事実を知るための情報
仏教よく言うんですね
我々は現象 幻覚の殻の中にいるんだ
だから調べる能力を与えても意味がないんですよ
本当に殻を破っちゃえば
全て知っているんです
その情報を知りましょうと
はい 知識と知恵 知識を智慧に変えるための情報必要です
知識とはストーリーなんです
例えば花を見たら これはバラのお花です
これは赤色のお花で この種類はこの種類ですと
ですから それストーリー作っているんです
いつでも我々何を見ても
そちらにストーリーを作る
で あのものを 2つ区別する場合でも
瞬間にストーリーを作っているんです
ただ 人の前にあのボールペン 2つ
3つ置いておく おく 覚えてくださいと
それからこれ取り出して
で また元の通りに並べておいてくださいと言うと
10人に 100点にできる人はストーリーを作っているんです
このボールペンはこうなって
こうなって こういうことで
こんな感じで これはこういうこういうことな感じ
まあ 3番目はこれで これでこうやってという風にストーリーを作っているんです
ですから バラバラになっちゃっても元に戻すことができるようになっちゃうんですね
だからそれにあるべきことなんですね
だからそれは知識というんですね
知識をどうやって知恵にするのかという方法を学ぶ情報を取った方がいいんです
はい 次 輪廻転生を乗り越えるための必要な情報
はい 次 それで仏教的にこれ役に立つ項目をまあ青天のようにもう書いて書いて出しました
最後に輪廻転生を乗り越えるための情報しか人に役に立ちません
他の情報は輪廻転生を伸ばしちゃうんです
苦しみを増やしちゃうんです
だから唯一情報とは輪廻転生を乗り越える情報なんです
それはサンユッタニカーヤの膨大なところで
膨大なお釈迦様説かれているんですよ
データの選択と なんで私はこれしか喋ってないのかと
もう森の葉っぱすべてのほどのことを知ってますよと
喋ったの手に握っている枯れ葉のぐらいやと
他役に立たんやと これ知ったらみんな苦しみをなくせますよと
だからまあ本当に私たちは苦労しなくても
お釈迦様は全てもう恐ろしい智慧で
もう選択検索してデータ出しているんです
だからせっかくお釈迦様が検索してデータ出したんだから
あの検索エンジンには誰もかなわないんだから
それで出したデータ完璧だから
それそのまま理解すればいいのに
やらないね 人間は はい
だからそれから実践のところに行きます
あの この検索能力っていうのは
至って簡単な実践の方法っていうのは
自分を知ることなんですね
自分を知る人は全てを知るんです
みんな笑っちゃう え？だって自分がいるからでしょ？全てあるのは
全て自分に関わる自分の存在に関係あるものでしょ
ネットであろうが 携帯であろうが
自分が死んじゃったらね
携帯は意味がないでしょうに
死んじゃった人が携帯に携帯と言わない
もう死んでるんだから
だから生きている ここがポイントなんです
こちらの問題を知ったならば
もう全て知ってるんです
ネットにある膨大な情報も
同じ問題に悩んでいる人々の叫び声しかないんです
自分を知ること知らないで
あれも知ったこれも知った
珍しい魚の写真撮りましたとか
あるいは動物は違う種類の動物は仲良くする場面をキャプチャー撮り撮れたとか
そんなもんばっかしで
うん ですから 無数無限の情報から自分を知るための情報のみを選択するんですよ
本当にカップいっぱいになります
データは 水道の水じゃないんです
水道の水 全部知る必要ないんです
カップ一杯になります
自分を知るために必要なものだけ勉強しましょうってことなんです
はい 続けていきます  １００トンの
これ どう読むんですかね
金 金鉱石 金鉱石 砕いている１０グラムの純金に価値があります
例えで使ったんだけど
あまりいい例えじゃないんですね
借金というか 砂の場合でも大量のトラック何台も来て綺麗にしてして
ほんのわずかな金しか取れないんです
膨大だからって それは役に立たない
だから膨大無制限のデータの中で
自分を知るためのほんのわずかなカップ一杯ぐらいのデータがあるんです
それは知りましょう で
ブッダがこう語るんです
サハッサンピチェーチャーアナッタパダサンヒタエーカンガアッタパダンセイヨゥヤンスッタウパサンマティ
訳は役に立たない千の言葉より
心に安穏を与える一つの言葉が優れている
だから 膨大な１２ボリューム ２３冊の膨大な歴史小説を読む読んだっても
ただ無駄で 一言葉二言葉で十分だと
人に心に安穏をもたらすならばと
だからお釈迦様ははっきりと具体的に膨大なデータ捨てなさいと言っているんです
自分に必要なデータだけ取ってください
それはこれだよと明確に定義しているんです
うん それから世の中で悪情報あります
これ勉強しなくちゃいけないです
慈しみに反する知識情報は悪です
へっちゃらで流しているでしょ
人類の平和 安穏 慈しみ
思いやり そういうものに邪魔する情報
何であろうとも悪なんです
はい 貪瞋痴の感情を掻き回す情報は悪です
結構みんな悪やってますよ
芸術的 文化的 いろんなことをやってます
世の中で貪瞋痴を掻き回したいんですね
結局は残念ながら悪なんです
他に誤解を招く情報は悪ですね
まあそれは一部は法律的にも悪にしていますね
例えば危険なフェイクニュース流しちゃうと
これはもう法律を犯したことになりますね
自分の苛立ち 不安と憎しみなどの感情の表れの言葉が悪です
時々人はただ喋ってますよ
相手にもう相手が一生です
誰か聞いてくれる人は
でも情報を伝えているのは自分の気持ちがギャーギャーギャーギャーギャーギャー言ってるだけで
すごい危険な言葉 そのとか言ったりもするんですね
全て悪なんです うん 戦争
戦いなどを支える平和を壊す情報は悪です
はい そんな悪情報ですね
はい 次に行きます 事実を知り得ない
情報社会 今は情報社会でしょ？面白い現象
特色があります 情報社会だからこそ
事実は知ることはできないんです
何がどうなっているか
さっぱり誰もわからない世界なんです
はい ポイントに行きます
ネット時代だから何でも知れると思ってはならない
逆なんです うん ほとんど無駄な情報だけですね
あるのは 人は自分の気持ち
感情を支える情報に惹かれますから
人格は退化します この現代
いくらでも情報入れますからね
そこで自分たちが自分の感情を掻き立てる情報だけ取る
自分の好みの情報だけ取る
自分の怒り 嫉妬 憎しみに合う情報だけ取る
自分の偏見に合う情報だけ取る
自分の差別意識を支える情報だけ取る
それで個人が破壊してしまうんです
これは現代はとても危険な状況なんです
なぜならば 情報はオープンです
無限に情報があるんです
それから危険なのは 情報を発信する人には責任がないんです
コントロールないんです
何でも言っちゃえばいいっていうことなんです
フリーに発言できる だから発言者は自己戒め
慈しみ 他人の役に立つというコントロールは一切ないんです
いわゆる野生精神なんです
野生野蛮 野蛮 野蛮な精神でフリーに発言しなさいっていうのは情報社会なんです
情報はコントロールしませんと
それで受け取る側の責任やと言ってますよ
はっきりと それで受け取る側にももう野蛮人なんですね
自分の気持ちをコントロールしていないので
だから怒りの人は怒りを燃やしてくれる情報を取る
欲が異常欲な人は異常欲を燃やす情報を取る
差別的な人々は差別情報を取る
それでアメリカの雑誌で読んだんだけど
このアメリカの今 COVID19 で攻撃を受けているんだから
あのホワイトスプリマシーという白人主義者たちがとてもありがたいことやと
このウイルスあることはね
これはどんどん他の黒人やらヒスパニックやら白人でない連中にどんどんもうなんていうもう感染させた方がいいやと
だから自分にが感染しているならば
できるだけ人に移してくださいというふうなサイトで載せているみたいんです
だから そのサイトはそれほどアクセス数はなかったんだけど
この最近いきなり 1500人ぐらいアクセス数が増えたと
だから 悪人には何でも悪感情だから COVID19
で人が死んでいくんだから心配するべきでしょうに
自分個人にできる範囲でもう病気に打ち勝つために協力するべきでしょうに
これはいい武器に使いましょうと
いうことっていうのは
どんな人間ですかね だから
その人々は悪いと私は一概には言いたくはないんですよ
みんな同じですから だから私たちもフリーアクセスできたら
自分の悪感情を育てるデータだけ取っちゃいますから
人格が退化することだけは確かなんです
ですから お釈迦様は選んだ役に立つ情報にもうもうトリミングしなくちゃいけないんです
はい 次に行きましょう
それからストーリーは事実ではないということを理解しましょう
人は眼耳鼻舌身意 眼耳鼻舌身意にある色声香味触法の純粋データを意でストーリーに組み立てるんです
まあはっきり言います
目にはバラの花見えませんよ
目には光が触れるだけ
どんな人の目にも同じ光触れるんです
この光情報で頭の中で意の中でストーリーを作るんです
だから一人がまあつまらないバラの花ですとかね
なんだバラかいというストーリーも作る
結構綺麗ですねというストーリーを作る人
いろいろ だから我々は知識っていうのはこのストーリーなんです
うん 他人に伝えるのはのは
家で捏造したストーリーです
だから世の中で情報社会で情報が流れているわけじゃないんです
みんな捏造したストーリーを流してるんです
だからストーリーが事実じゃないんです
はい ストーリーに知識とラベルを貼っているだけ
知識人だと 知識人じゃないんです
ただたくさんストーリーを
あり得もないストーリーを覚えているだけ
脳を壊しているだけ うん
知識人になっても事実は知らないんです
ですから 知識人だと威張っても
あんた何も知らないねとはっきり言えます
仏教の立場からね はい
次に行きます じゃあブッダの立場に
ストーリーは何通りで何通りでもですね
作れますから 信頼性はゼロなのでまず捨てます
これからアドバイスしていきます
ストーリーっていうのは何通りでも作られます
あの子供にこの粘土をあげたような感じで
何でも作れます ですから
同じ場所にいて  1時間ぐらい付き合っていても
一人一人の感想が違う
一人一人のストーリーが違う
だから事実はどういうことかと
あんたあの会議に行ったの？とかね
行きましたよと どういうことを何を喋ったの？その人は言う
もう他の人に聞いたら
その人は別なストーリーを
だから会議の本当の状況は知ることはできないので
自分自身で会議に参加しても
自分のストーリーで理解するんです
ですから ストーリー捨てましょうと
捨てなさいとお釈迦さんははっきり言うんです
うん それから厳密にある四相交明即法というデータのみを観察します
これは結構難しい実験なんです
目を開けて物体を見るが
バラの花は見ないことなんです
でもこれ 光の速度でバラになっちゃいますでしょ
訓練するんです 見える
見える 見えると バラの花が消えて
本当にデータが受け取れるとまで
はい 自分好みのストーリーを組み立て組み立てたくなる気持ち
欲求を捨てます そこでこの実践する人は一発で成功しませんだけど
ストーリーは組み立てない
初心者を組み立てますよ
食べ物を見てたら食べ物ですとかね
あ そばですと言った時はもうストーリーなんです
そばですと言った時のそばに対するストーリーが頭の中で
子供の頃から今までの経験で出来上がったストーリーが出てくるんです
それで修行を続けると
見たら食べ物ですと そばですと言わない
今 今度は食べ物ですと
でもそれもストーリーです
そばと実況したよりはマシですけど
ストーリーです 食べ物で言ったら
食べ物についての妄想のストーリー世界がまた出てくるんです
そこで集中力をかけると見えている
終わっちゃう 食べ物ですというのはなくなっちゃうんです
見えている それで事実なんです
見えているだけ そこでその人にちょっと余裕があるんで
見えているところはこんな風に組み立ててストーリー作るんだよと
昔はそばです 私のなんだらかんだらですとかね
それが食べ物です それは進んだところで食べ物ですとストーリー作った
それからどんな生命でも食べ物を食べなくちゃいけないんだからしょうがないというストーリーになったと
今見えているだけ ストーリーはゼロ
目がるから見えているだけ
風に順番で進んでいくんです
それで知る過程のからくりを発見します
知るってどういうこと？耳に空気の振動が触れる
それで頭の中でストーリーが出来上がっちゃう
感情の荒波 津波が 津波が現れる
これでこれでこれでこれで
これで最後に津波っていう感じで順番に見ることはできます
すごい能力ですよ 空気の振動
聴覚 それから音 それから音楽
それであれやこれやと
何々さんの音楽 もうまあ
それからもう感情の荒波
それは知恵と呼びますけど
そのプロセスを知っている人には知恵があるんです
知恵に達した人は 生命に関するすべてを知っていると言えるんです
これ知ったらすべて知ってるでしょ
どんな人間でも犬猫でもコウモリでもミミズでもやってるのはそれでしょ
触れるデータからストーリー作ることでしょう
だからみんなのことも知ってるんです
もうネットは問題じゃないんです
ですから 自分を知る人はすべてを知る
だから今そうって言ったのは
このカット カットして捨てる
カットして捨てる方法で言ったでしょ
言って 我々はすべて知る状態に達するんです
次に行きます そこでこのローカビデュ
ローカビデュというのはお釈迦様に対する言葉なんで
世間芸っていうのは世間のことを何でも知ってるっていう意味になっちゃうんですね
こうやって誤解する 誤解するしてしまう恐れが
もう狙ってダジャレ狙ってお釈迦様が使っている単語なんです
ブッダは世間を知り尽くしているという意味なんです
皆 ブッダが全知全知全知者だと
何でも知っているのだと理解したがるんですね
仏教とはみんなそうなんです
お釈迦様なら何でも知ってるんだと
で そうやって気持ちで理解したがるんです
で これは罠です はい 生命が根源するストーリーのすべてを知っているとはあり得ない
異常な考えです だからみんな思っているのは
お釈迦様が生命が作るどんなストーリーも知ってるんだよと
ハチャメチャでしょうに
だってきりがないでしょうね
たとえおにぎり見ても
その人はどんなストーリー作るのかと定めていないでしょうに
朝起きた時 おにぎりを見る
布団に入って寝ようかなと
お風呂にも入って もうじゃあ寝ようかなと思ったら
棚に置いているおにぎりを見る
同じストーリー作る？作らないでしょうに
朝起きておにぎりを見る
9時ぐらいで見る だからその都度その都度人は無数のストーリーを作る
それすべてお釈迦様は知ってる
知ってどうする？ゴミでしょうに
なんでゴミ箱を明確にゴミを処分するものでしょうね
調べるんですかね これ
みんなこの罠に大体仏教の方々はね
このハマってるんですね
見事に はい ストーリーは妄想だから捨てるんです
お釈迦様はそんなのは捨ててるんで
人のストーリーには乗りません
逆に相手に聞くんです
だってなんでお釈迦様は先知全能だったら人に質問する
あなたはなんでどういうことで悩んでいる？と質問してるでしょ？経典見たら先知の先知だったら聞く必要ないでしょ
汝はなんだらかんだらことで今悩んでるでしょうと言えばいいでしょうと
言ってない ストーリーには乗ってないんです
ストーリーは捨てているんです
だから相手にあなたのストーリーは何ですかと聞いてるんです
はい ローカミドということは
お釈迦様だから みんななんかにナゾナゾかけてご自分で定義しているんです
この経典の一部なんです
ある人が昔々話のストーリーですけど
ロヒタッサという超能力者なんですね
宇宙空間移動できる人なんです
スペーストラベルできた人なんです
ちょっと隣の惑星に行ってるわけじゃなくて
宇宙空間トラベルできた人なんです
で 自分の能力で この人はこれぐらいもう高速光の速度よりも早く
スペーストラベリングできますから
宇宙の果てに行ってみますと
行きました 行って行って
進んで進んで 途中で寿命が終わって死んじゃったんです
そこである人にこうやって宇宙のことを考える場合
お釈迦様はこの人のことを言ってね
宇宙の果てっていうのは
この歩いて行けるものじゃない
この歩くっていうのは
日本の足で歩くんじゃなくて
この光の速度を飛ばして
心のスピードでスペーストラベリングなんですよ
それを仏教は歩くと言うんですね
とても果てには行かないんだと
しかし 宇宙果てに行かなきゃダメだよと
苦しみはなくなりませんよと
だからロカっていう場合
お釈迦様は宇宙全体という言葉にちょっと微妙に言い換えるんです
入れてスペーストラベリングでは宇宙の果てには行けないし
宇宙の果てに行かない限りは苦しみは終わらないし
どうしようかと そこで
汝に私は言います アピチャコハンアウソ
イマスミンエヴァビャワマッテマッテーカレバレ
ササンイッミサマナケ
ローカンチャパンニャーペーミローカサムダーンチャ
ローカニローダンチャ
ローカニロードガーミニンチャパティパダンティと説かれたんです
これはものすごい厳しい言葉なんです
一人称で語っているんです
はい 見に行きます ひとひらのひとひら
人の身長ですね この感覚がある体の中で
ちょっと言葉一つ抜けています
感覚がある体の中で世間
世間の原因 世間の滅 世間の滅に至る道があると私は解きますと
この 4つですね これは空・住・滅・道に合わせてるんです
ですから苦・集・態ありますね
苦イコール世間なんです
これは体の苦しみなんですね
だからこの人 何でしたっけ？ひとひろの体で宇宙をすべて知ることできますよと
お釈迦様は断言的に語る
それすごいと思います
だから普通 まあ三人称で語るんです
お釈迦様は 真理が俗世間の思考と真っ向から違う場合は
ブッダが一人称で語るんです
責任持って語るんです
私が言いますからと だから文句あったらブッダに当たりなさいと
だからお釈迦様 我々は本当にいい加減喋るでしょ
言葉を発した人がその言葉の責任持たなくちゃいけないです
みんなそれやってないんですね
へっちゃらで何でもかんでも言う
だからものすごく気をつけなくてはいけないんです
喋る言葉っていうのは世間に発信するんです
だから自分が発信元なんです
だから何かあったら自分が責任持たなくちゃいけないんです
だからお釈迦様が三人称で語るんです
三人称で語ったのは自我がないからなんです
ブッダだからなんです
しかし いくつかの場所であえて一人称を入れるんです
私が語りますと ということは
ものすごい強烈な言葉ということになるんです
だから このひとひろの体で宇宙をすべて知ることはできますし
宇宙の果てに達して解脱に達することもできますので
膨大なデータは関係ないということになります
はい ローカルの問題はそれぐらいです
ですから 仏道実践者も世間芸になれますよ
頑張ってみましょう はい
次に行きます 検索達人
私はこのポイントはちょっと今日扱わないで忘れたことにしようかなと思っていて
もしかすると今 1時間 2時間ぐらいになったね
だから忘れた方がいいと思います
ブッダが宇宙単位の時間で過去のことを遡って知ることはできたんです
だからお釈迦様はこれ数珠までこれぐらい
これぐらい これぐらい見たんだよとかね
は書かれては説かれてはあります
必要なデータのみを検索する
その技が人間の理解範囲を超えています
だからそれは真似できませんし
理解することすらできないんです
どうやって宇宙 例えば宇宙一つ現れて
また消えてまた現れて
この間すっと知っているのかと
これは違う技なんです
はい 阿羅漢の聖者にも真似できません
阿羅漢になってもこれだけできません
はい そこでちょっと時間ありますから
ほんのちょっと言います
あのブッダに あの なんかあの遺伝子の問題で体がすごいちっちゃくてなったティッサという人がいたんですね
体が伸びないんですね
まあたまにはいますね
我々の腰の程度ですけど
立派な 40歳  60歳の大人なんですね
身長は そういう人が出家して阿羅漢になったんですね
お釈迦様はものすごく偉大なる人やとね
褒めるんです だからこのしかし
なんでこの阿羅漢になってお釈迦様にも褒められるぐらい徳のあるこの人が
なんで遺伝子問題で成長ホルモンが出てこなかったと
現代的にはそれでしょう
遺伝子に問題があって
成長ホルモンが現れなかったんです
成長もいろいろある 身長を伸ばすホルモンですね
で それでお釈迦様が検索するんです
それは技はもう一般人には理解できないんですね
だからそれ心に業が働いていて
この業にそれで鍵があるんですね
成長させないところ この鍵を見つけて
それは過去どこでも遡って
この似ているところはどこか
鍵はどこで現れたのかとサッと見つけて
このストーリーを言うんです
あんたはこれこれこれ前にこういうこういうことをやりましたから
今こうなっているんだよと
だからこれはもう あの業は人に読めないんです
阿羅漢にも読めないんです
だからこれはブッダだけの能力なんです
はい 最後に行きます 私たちの道
読み読むだけにします
何でも知る必要ありません
知ること 知らないこと
知る必要はないことを明確にする
だからそういうふうに分けましょうよ
何かが知らないとは恥ずかしいことではありませんよ
全然恥ずかしくないんです
うん 何でも知りは何も役に立つほどのほど程度で
知らない 何ですか？なんか私もわからなくなっちゃった
何でも知り屋の人々いるんですね
あの人々は何も役に立つものを知らないんです
本当に役に立たないんです
だから 1個 2つでいいんです
役に立つものが知っていれば
だから知らないものは無数にあっても構いません
恥ずかしく思う必要はないんです
はい 善と悪を知りましょう
それが必要です これは善
これは悪と うん 体 言葉
心の行為がいかに善になるか
悪になるか知った方がいいんです
だって我々は身口意で行為しているでしょ
この方法を知らないと
ただ喋ればいいんじゃないんです
喋る場合は 善になる喋り方知った方が
悪になる 喋り方しない方がよろしいんですね
それは知る価値があります
はい 知ってるものは役に立たないならば復習して思い出す必要はありません
いろいろ知ってるけど
役に立たんだったら忘れ
自然に忘れてもいいんです
うん 脳は大量のデータを捨てるにかけているでしょ
我々は気づかなくても相当データセンターでかけてます
だから 24時間  20時間といっても
まあずっと今もいろんなデータを取っていますよ
私は喋ることに集中していますけど
見えるもの あれやこれや
他の音とか脳が認識していますけど
全部捨てていくんです
だから忘れるってことは別に悪いことじゃないんです
みんな だから大事なことを忘れるというのはことにしますけどね
はい 人格向上するために必要な情報を取り入れましょう
心が熱望するストーリーは一時的に使用できますが
執着しないようにしましょう
これは説明必要です 我々は一時的にストーリー使えます
例えば この今こちら何かの機械がありまして
私はこれをマイクロフォンやとストーリーを作るんです
そのストーリーで役に立ちますけど
マイクロフォンといったことには執着する必要はないんです
それはある程度で役に立つだけで
今私の前にいるサリーちゃんには
これはマイクロフォンではありません
だからストーリーは一時的に役に立つ
それから執着しないで置いておく
はい 自分を知ることに励みましょう
終わりですね はい 最終的には自分を知ることに励みましょう
それが全て知っている道になります
ありがとうございます
あの ちょっと分かりづらいんですけど
少年とサンマーサティとあと少女サンマーサマーディの関係性について知りたい
あ それはあのペアというか
繋いでいますね あの少年があると
少女様様でも少年のレベルに合わせて現れます
サンマーサティということも同じことですからね
だから気づきとサマーディがつないでいるんです
だから私たちにはこのサマーディだけ育てることはできますけど
それでちょっと別にヴィパッサナー瞑想をやる羽目になるんですね
だから仏教では気づき
少年を実践するんです
少年を実践すると症状がついてくるんですね
こう理解しましょうか
あと お盆の上に何かコーヒーカップあるとかね
だからカップを持って皿を持って
カップの皿を持って それからお盆を取るという方法もあります
3回 皿をする お盆を取る
一回 ３つも取ってますね
だからどちらでも同じことですけど
例えばあのお盆の上にコーヒーカップがありますね
それは片付けなくちゃいけない
だからまずカップを持っていて片付けて
それからカップの皿を持っていて片付けて
それからお盆を持って片付けるという方法も正しいんですよ
しかし そのまま丸ごとお盆で取って
お盆を持っていて全部片付けるという方法もありますね
だから少年実践すると少女はついてきます
はい  はい 今の方で あの
ちょっと追加の質問があったんですけど
えっと 四念処の信受身法ありますよね
それっていうのは その禅定の 4つの禅定ありますよね
それと何か関係がある？ あれは関係ないな
それは関係ないんです
ということです はい 質問はこのくらいですかね
はい 最後の誓願の偈を唱えて終了します
ドゥッカパッタンタチェニン
ドゥッカバヤンパンターチェニン
バヤショーカパッタンターチェニッショーカホントゥサンデーピパーニノ
苦しむものの苦しみがなくなりますように
怯えるものの怯えが消えますように
悲しむものの悲しみがなくなりますように
一切の生命がかくのごとくありますように
長い時間どうもありがとうございました
ありがとうございました
カンティパラマンタポティティンカーニッバーナナンパラマンワダンティブッダ